hi I'm Pam Holt of Buda dog animal
massage I'm a registered veterinary
technician and a certified animal
massage therapist I've been in business
about 11 and a half years and I think
it's the best job in the world
the
even the lightest massage will release
endorphins the body's natural pain
reliever so it just makes them feel good
the light strokes help them relax
hopefully they are just in bliss
massage is a form of passive exercise so
you're kind of realigning the muscle
fibers by doing the stretches after
massage little dogs like Emma sometimes
you get the luxating patella issue or
kneecaps so I want to give a little
extra attention you're ruining the scene
vesko fest I'll be back a future presto
dogs do so much for us and so it's nice
to see them get get some special
treatment and enjoy something you want
to make sure you're in the right frame
of mind you're massaging an animal
because there is an energy transfer and
just enjoy this quiet bonding time with
your animal
you'll relax now give you a massage at
home all right
you